[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYA WADHWA: So welcome
to Developing Faster
on Kubernetes.
We're going to show you how
to use GoogleContainerTools
in Cloud Build.
So let's get started.
DAVID GAGEOT: So
I'm David Gageot.
I'm a developer advocate
based out of Paris, France,
and I love everything
that's related to developer
experience, and I love cats.
And there's no connection
between the two.
And you can reach me
on Twitter and GitHub.
PRIYA WADHWA: Hey, everyone.
My name is Priya Wadhwa.
I'm a software engineer in GCP.
I work on a bunch of
different open-source tools
like Skaffold,
Kaniko, and Minikube.
And that's my GitHub and
Twitter if anyone's interested.
DAVID GAGEOT: OK.
PRIYA WADHWA: So
let's talk about what
it's like to be a developer
in Kubernetes, working
on Kubernetes.
Who here already
develops on Kubernetes?
Raise your hands.
And who is interested in
developing on Kubernetes?
OK, cool.
We're going to talk more
about what that's like
and making your
workflows a bit faster.
DAVID GAGEOT: Do you like it?
Being a developer in
Kubernetes as well?
OK, because this is our opinion.
PRIYA WADHWA: Yeah.
DAVID GAGEOT: Our
opinion is that, yeah--
PRIYA WADHWA: Yeah.
Kubernetes is
really cool, and you
can deploy some awesome
applications, but sometimes
the process of
developing on Kubernetes
can be time-consuming
and difficult.
So we're going to talk about
making it a bit easier.
So let's talk about what a
typical workflow deploying
to Kubernetes might look like.
So I have this really
simple Go application
which just prints out,
"Hello, Wprld!" every second.
So I want to deploy this
application to Kubernetes.
And I'm going to
start by making sure
that it works as I expect
with a simple go run.
So it looks pretty good.
And at this point, I need to
containerize my Go application
so that I can deploy
to Kubernetes later.
So I have this
Docker file, and I'm
going to build my container
with a Docker build.
Cool.
And at this point, I would
normally push my image,
but I'm using a local
cluster, so I don't have to.
And to deploy this
container to Kubernetes,
I have this pod spec.
And I can deploy to Kubernetes
with the kubectl apply command.
So we have our pod created.
We can take a look at our logs.
And they look pretty good.
It's what I expect.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yeah,
it's deploying.
PRIYA WADHWA: It's deployed!
But what if I want to make
a change to my application
and I want to say
something else?
So the first thing that I need
to do is go back into my main
.go file and make my change.
So maybe you want to say,
"Hello, Next" instead.
So I need to rebuild
my image now.
But this time, I'm going
to tag with a v2 tag
so that we can version
control our containers.
And then I would push my image.
And the next thing I need
to do is patch my YAML file.
DAVID GAGEOT: That's a super
interesting job, right?
Fetching YAML files.
PRIYA WADHWA: And then
reapply my new pod.yaml spec.
And if we check the logs,
it looks pretty good.
DAVID GAGEOT: That's a lot
of commands that you typed.
PRIYA WADHWA: Yeah, that
was a lot of commands.
And basically,
this whole process
is what me and David
call the infinite loop
of pain and suffering.
[LAUGHTER]
Even the smallest code
change requires a ton
of commands in my terminal.
I have to rebuild my image,
remember to tag it differently,
push my image, patch my
YAML with the new tag,
run a kubectl apply, and then
verify that the changes I made
are actually what
I wanted to see.
And any error at any
point in the cycle
can result in me having to
go back and debug and spend
a lot of time trying to
fix whatever went wrong.
So people often solve this
issue with batch scripts,
and make files, and they'll
automate parts of this cycle
away.
But is there an even easier way?
DAVID GAGEOT: I hope there is.
[LAUGHTER]
PRIYA WADHWA: Well, there is.
DAVID GAGEOT: OK.
So the first tool we're going
to talk about is Skaffold.
Skaffold is a CLI,
open-source tool
that you can find on GitHub
under the Google Container
Tools organization.
And you can just download
it and get started.
And it gives you iterative
development for Kubernetes,
whether you're working with
a local or a remote cluster.
It works on any cloud provider,
any instance of Kubernetes.
And I said, it's open-source.
So how do you use Skaffold.
So I'm sorry to tell you that
before you can use Skaffold,
you have to write
more YAML files.
Are you OK with that?
Because if you don't
like YAML files,
don't touch Kubernetes, OK?
[LAUGHTER]
But Skaffold makes it easy for
us to not write this YAML file.
We have a common
called skaffold init
that if we try to
introspect my sources,
and we'd find the Docket
files, and the YAML manifest,
and we tried to match them so
that I've got a Skaffold that's
YAML pregenerated for me.
So at least one artifact,
it leaves the YAML
that Priya showed you.
I'm going to say, yeah, I think
it's the right configuration.
So now that I have this
configuration with my sources,
I can do nice commands such as--
not that-- skaffold build.
Skaffold build, not
truly interesting,
It's just doing part of the
cycle that Priya showed you.
It's going to
build your images--
this time it does
only one image.
It's going to tag it.
That's interesting,
because you don't
have to think about the tag.
Remember when Priya
switched from v1 to v2
because she knew she
changed something?
Skaffold will do it for
you based on Git tags.
But you can do something
more interesting.
You can do skaffold run.
Skaffold run will build your
image, will tag your images,
will take the tag,
put them in the YAML,
and send it to Kubernetes,
which is quite nice.
But you can also do
skaffold run --tail,
and this time it does the
whole cycle in one command.
It will show you the logs
of all the containers
that were built and
deployed by Skaffold.
So this is the full cycle
that Priya showed you
with only one command.
PRIYA WADHWA: Awesome.
DAVID GAGEOT: Awesome.
Who want to try a
Skaffold already?
A few people.
OK, we're going to
try to have more.
Because you're
developers-- you told us
you were a developers-- we're
going to do skaffold dev, which
is just for you.
It's exactly the
same, but it will also
watch for file changes, so
that when you change something
in any of your
artifacts, it will
rebuild that image and redeploy
what needs to be redeployed.
Let me show that to you.
I'm going to open a new tab,
and I'm going to change my code.
OK.
Typo.
Double-typo.
I'm going to save it.
And boom, Skaffold
detects that, rebuilds
my image, retag, change
the YAML, redeploy,
gives me the update
[? cheat ?] logs, OK?
So to sum up, you just
concentrate on your code.
You don't have to think
about that whole cycle.
All the commands, you
can forget about them.
Just learn one
command-- skaffold dev.
So who wants to try
Skaffold on Monday
when they're back to work?
OK.
Yeah, a bit more.
OK, cool.
But there's one problem.
We showed you that
you changed something,
and it's very quick to rebuild.
But in real life,
building a Docker image
doesn't take 2 seconds, right?
Who has Docker builds that
deck more than 10 seconds
or 30 seconds, or?
OK.
It can be very, very long.
I took a Java example here
to show you the problem
if you don't know it.
So who's a Java developer here?
OK, same problem applies to
Python or Node, or whatever.
It's always faster to build
your applications locally
on your machine than
with Docker containers.
So here is a Java application.
So usually, to build it,
you would run such command.
Because it was built
already on my machine,
it takes only a few
seconds to build.
I can build it two times--
it takes 2 seconds, OK?
Now, I've got a Docker file.
I want to containerize
my application.
So I've got a Docker file which
is already quite complicated
to write.
There's quite a few
tricks in that Docker
file to make it nice with you.
And I'm going to
build my application.
It's going to be very quick,
because I've built it already
on my machine.
But now, I'm going to change
something in the code.
I'm going to change a comment.
Oops, where am I?
I'm going to change just
the comment here, OK?
How long do you
think it will take
to rebuild the Docker image?
10 seconds?
One minute?
Two minutes?
Four minutes?
OK.
The thing is, is that
it's going to redownload
all the dependencies from my
projects-- all the plugins.
So it's going to take maybe four
minutes on a slow connection.
And it's going to be more than
that on a very slow connection.
So this is the problem
with Docker builds.
It has a smart
caching mechanism,
but it will never be as quick as
what you have on your machine.
Because here, I change
something in the pom.yml.
It has no impact on
what's on my artifacts,
on my build artifact, but it
has an impact on Docker caching.
So it has to redownload all the
plugins, which is really not
nice.
Just that far a "Hello
World!" application.
So we're going to show you a
second open-source tool called
Jib.
Jib stands for
Java Image Builder.
It's open-source.
You can also find it
on GitHub, same org--
Google Container Tools.
It's a Maven and
Gradle plugin that you
can use to build Docker images
without even installing Docker
without writing a Docker file,
without learning the Docker
file syntax.
And it gives you fast,
incremental builds.
So I think the Java
developers in the room
will really like it.
All you have to do
is add a new plugin
to your Java configuration--
just that.
You select this Jib plugin.
It's the same application.
And now I'm going to run a
slightly different command.
I'm going to do a maven
compile jib:build,
and give it the name of the
image that it should produce.
And with that command, it
will build my application.
And when it's done, it's going
to produce a Docker image
and push it in 4 seconds.
I can change the comment in the
YAML if you want and rebuild.
It should also be
about 4 seconds.
Because everything was
already built on my machine,
it's using the cache
that's on my machine.
It's not using the Docker cache.
So maybe you think that's
not very important.
But when you're using skaffold
dev, and you change something,
and you focus on your code,
you don't want the rebuild
to take a few minutes.
You want it to be as
quick as possible.
Jib is one solution.
There are other solutions that
we won't talk about, but just
know that there
are people who try
to make it very quick
for you so that you
can focus on your code.
One last thing I wanted to say
is that Skaffold and Jib is not
just for "Hello World!"
It works very well
with a "Hello World!"
simple, but here we have
a much bigger project.
It's a multi-microservices
application
based on six microservices.
Each of them has a Docker
image, and each of them
is in a separate directory.
And we have more YAML
manifests-- yeah, YAML--
what we want to deploy.
And because I've got
this Skaffold YAML,
I can run skaffold dev, and it's
going to rebuild all my images.
It's going to tag them.
It's going to put all the
tags in the YAML files,
deploy everything,
show me the logs
for all the containers at once.
See?
It's deployed, and
I can see the logs.
That's nice, right?
So it's not just
for "Hello World!"
And if I change something,
because I'm dev mode--
like, for example, I will
change some Java application,
some Java code.
I'm going to change
the title here.
It's the Google Cloud
Quiz for Next '19.
Save it.
And boom, Skaffold
will detect that,
will run jib build, and redeploy
this application for me.
So it deployed
only what's needed.
And boom, my
application is there.
I have a very quick feedback.
And if I change something,
like a static web page,
it can be even faster.
I'm going to add
some exclamation
marks, because I like them.
[LAUGHTER]
Boom, it's already deployed.
Let me do that for you again,
because it was too quick.
OK.
Save, boom.
Skaffold synced the
file from my machine
to the running pod
on a remote cluster.
I don't even have to
rebuild the images.
So it's really as quick as
if I was working locally.
So you really get the 10x
velocity with Skaffold.
So this is a schema just to
explain what Skaffold did.
So you add all these
components-- the UI, the title,
the game, the
database, et cetera--
all of them in
different folders.
Skaffold will watch the sources
for all those components.
And for some components,
it will sync the files
to the remote cluster.
For some components, it will
run jib build to make sure
that the Java application
is rebuilt on your machine.
And for the rest,
it will do Docker
build, which will be a
little bit slower, but still
very, very nice.
And all the ports for
all the containers
are ports forwarded
locally on my machine.
So that if I connect
to remote cluster--
I'm going to connect
on GKE, which is
a cluster, always more nodes.
Nope.
OK.
I can run the same
skaffold dev command,
and this time it needs to
push the images remotely,
but most of them
were already pushed,
and Skaffold knows that.
It's got a very smart,
aggressive caching mechanism
that Priya developed.
It's the reason
why it's so quick.
But some of the images are
changed in front of you,
so they need to be
rebuilt and pushed.
And when it's done, I
will be able to connect
to my remote
cluster the same way
as I was connecting
on the local cluster.
It's almost there.
Yeah.
So I'm connected on local host.
But in fact, I'm connected
to my remote cluster
thanks to port forwarding.
And I've got the
exact same experience.
If I change something here--
more exclamation marks--
it's going to be
synced automatically.
Was it?
Yeah.
I think it was.
No, maybe not.
There's a bug.
OK, it happens.
[LAUGHTER]
That's Skaffold.
PRIYA WADHWA: That's Skaffold.
So David just talked about
using Jib to make your builds
a little bit faster.
Skaffold also
supports using Bazel.
So you can build
locally with Docker,
you can build on the
cloud with Google Cloud,
or you can build your images
on a Kubernetes cluster
with Kaniko.
We also support testing with
container structure tests
and deploying your application
with kubectl, Kustomize,
or Helm.
So if you use any of these
tools already in your Kubernetes
application
development workflow,
you can just keep using them.
As long as you put that stuff
into your Skaffold YAML,
Skaffold will be smart enough
to know to deploy or build
with the tools
you're already using.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yeah.
This is very important
for the Skaffold team
that you keep the tools
you like, like Help,
or Kustomize, a kubectl.
And they are
integrated in Skaffold
so that you can just
focus on the code.
And it will work with
any Kubernetes cluster--
GKE, any cloud provider,
on-prem, local, local desktop,
Minikube.
It's very important.
If you have a hybrid
setup or on-prem setup,
it works very well too.
So it gives us very
tight feedback loop.
And you should try it on Monday.
Like, Monday, OK?
[LAUGHTER]
PRIYA WADHWA: Cool.
So David show us how to
use Skaffold as a CLI tool.
But can it be even easier?
And, yes, it can.
So one of the teams
at Google just
released Cloud Code,
which is an IDE
extension that runs Skaffold
for you directly from your IDE.
So it basically does
everything we just showed.
Skaffold runs skaffold
dev, but from the comfort
of IntelliJ or VS Code, if
you use either of those.
DAVID GAGEOT: Who's
using Vs code here?
IntelliJ?
OK.
So all the room.
Almost.
PRIYA WADHWA: Awesome.
Cool.
So let's do a quick demo.
So I have this really
retro game of Tic-Tac-Toe.
And it's not very
colorful, so let's make
it a little bit prettier.
DAVID GAGEOT: You deployed
this on GKE, right?
Yeah.
PRIYA WADHWA: Yeah,
deployed on GKE.
So it's pretty simple,
just two microservices.
I have a Tic-Tac-Toe front
end written in JavaScript
and a colors microservice
written in Go.
And basically, this file
tells the application
what colors I want my X's and
O's to be for Tic-Tac-Toe.
So if I want to
change the colors
and make them a little
more interesting--
what's your favorite color.
David?
DAVID GAGEOT: I
don't know, blue.
PRIYA WADHWA: I
already did that one.
OK.
Green or purple.
DAVID GAGEOT: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
PRIYA WADHWA: So you saw I just
made some changes to my IDE,
and with Cloud
code, I don't even
have to leave the IDE to deploy
these changes to my cluster.
So you can see that with
Cloud Code I can deploy,
I can create a new GKE cluster.
I can run a continuous
deploy, which
is basically just the skaffold
dev loop that David was just
showing.
Every time I save a file in
my ID it'll rebuild my image
and push it to my cluster again.
So for now, I'm just going
to deploy my application
to my cluster.
And the cool thing
about Cloud Code
is if I have
different profiles, I
can choose to only deploy a
certain part of my application.
So I know I only changed
the colors microservice,
so I'm only going to
redeploy that piece.
DAVID GAGEOT: You
don't have to do it,
but it's nice to have
profiles to tweak your
build process or debug process.
PRIYA WADHWA: Yeah.
We can take a look at the
Skaffold YAML, actually,
and what that looks like.
But I have just a
simple Skaffold YAML
here with my two microservices
and path to the Docker files
for those images.
And then a profile for my colors
microservice, which will only
build and deploy that bit,
and then one for my front end
as well.
And if we take a look
at our Cloud Code logs,
we basically just did a Skaffold
run again, except this time,
directly from our IDE.
And we went through
the same process
that we've already been through,
except Cloud Code is really
nice, and it'll tell me when
my deployment has rolled out
and is successfully deployed.
So if we head back
over to our game,
we can see we have some colors.
DAVID GAGEOT: Colors.
PRIYA WADHWA: So
it was super easy.
I never had to leave my IDE.
And it also told me when it was
finished, which is really cool.
So Cloud Code also have
some fun other things.
It does Skaffold
YAML validation.
So if I wanted to add
an artifact here--
say I have a third microservice
which does something,
except this one is
built with Bazel.
So I can say start
typing in Bazel,
and Cloud Code will autofill
the rest of the YAML for me.
And I just have to put
in my Bazel target.
And also, we'll do
some validation.
So if I put in an integer
here, which it doesn't expect,
it'll let me know.
And if I hover over different
pieces of my Skaffold YAML.
it'll tell me what
those pieces mean
and what Skaffold
is expecting, which
is just really nice during
my development process.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yeah.
Cloud code gives you this
validation and documentation
on Skaffold YAML, but any
YAML manifests for Kubernetes.
So your deployments,
[? pods, ?] et cetera,
you have the online
documentation and validation.
PRIYA WADHWA: Exactly.
So it just makes the
Kubernetes development
a little bit easier.
Because I always have
to go and look up
what a pod spec is meant to look
like before I write a new one.
Cool.
Yeah.
So with Cloud Code for VS
Code, continuous deployment,
you can still run your
skaffold run and skaffold dev,
except this time just with a
button click from your IDE.
YAML manifest
validation and more--
so you can download
that today as well.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yeah.
PRIYA WADHWA: And then Cloud
Code for IntelliJ as well--
very similar.
But basically, it'll just
run Skaffold for you,
and you can keep focusing
on writing your code, which
is the best part.
DAVID GAGEOT: OK.
So we showed how
to develop locally,
whether it's on the command
line or using your favorite IDE.
But at some point, your
application will get bigger,
and you'll want to be
able to be on the cloud.
Because building on your
machine has its limits.
Especially if you have
lots of microservices,
you don't want to build all
of them in sequence locally.
So we're going to talk
about one of the managed
services we have on Google
Cloud, which is Cloud Build.
Cloud Build is
fully-manage, CI/CD product
that gives you extremely
fast builds that you can use
to automate your deployments.
So you can build Docker
images or any binaries,
you can run your tests, you
can run your integration tests,
you can deploy at the end
of your bill pipeline.
So you should really take
a look at Cloud Build,
and we're going to
show you how to use it.
So usually, to use
Cloud Build, you
end up submitting a Cloud Build
YAML through the command line
or through the UI.
This is a typical command
that you would run--
gcloud build submit,
and you give you
it the Cloud Build YAML.
And this is the content
of the Cloud Build YAML.
This is a list of steps that
are going to run on your code.
So Cloud Build will
clone you repo,
and will run Docker images
steps on your codebase.
For example, here,
this first step
will run NPM install
on your sources.
And then NPM run
test to make sure
that the unit tests are run.
And then it will
do a Docker build
to make sure to
produce a Docker image,
and this Docker image will
be pushed by Cloud Build.
So if I run this
command from my sources,
it will send my sources
and run all those commands
so that at the end
I've got a Docker
image that was not built on my
machine but built on the cloud.
But it's even easier if
you're using Skaffold.
I just wanted to
show you a few UIs,
but Priya is going
to show it later on.
So with Skaffold,
it's even easier.
Here's my small hexagon
example with all the artifacts,
and I added a small
profile just four lines.
And with this
profile, you can just
say, OK, if this
profile is activated,
it will not be locally on
your machine using Docker,
but you will build remotely on
the cloud, all the artifacts
in parallel.
Let me show that to you.
I'm going to just
switch back to Docker.
So I'm going to do a Skaffold
build not using this profile,
just to show you that it's
building locally using Docker.
And all the artifacts
were already built,
so Skaffold is very
quick to tell you that.
And I'm going to now activate
the Cloud Build profile.
So now, this time, Skaffold
should send resources
to Cloud Build and compile all
the artifacts on the cloud.
But because it's smart,
thanks to Priya's code,
it's going to find that
all those images already
exist remotely.
Some of them exist
with a different tag,
so it's just going
to retag them.
It's not even going to send
the source to Cloud Build.
That's nice, right?
So you can really
build very quickly.
But I'm going to
change something.
I'm going to change--
I don't know-- the UI here--
exclamation marks.
I told you I wanted
[LAUGHTER]
I'm going to skaffold
build with the profile.
This time, one of
the artifact does not
exist remotely in my registry.
So Skaffold will take the
sources, put them in a tarball,
sned it to Cloud
Build, trigger a Cloud
build run, which will then run
some commands on top of it.
Basically, you would
do a Docker build
and a Docker push at the end.
And it will be very quick.
And it's even
quicker when you have
lots of artifacts to be
rebuilt, because it's going
to build them in parallel.
And when it's done,
triggered will tell me.
So you see, you don't even
have to learn the Cloud Build
CLI, or API, or UI, you can
use the same tool, Skaffold,
on your Cloud Code
extension, and you're
going to build on the cloud.
Which is quite nice, right?
PRIYA WADHWA: And you don't have
to write that Cloud Build YAML.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yeah.
You don't have to learn it.
One less YAML file.
PRIYA WADHWA: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
That's the dream.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yeah,
that's the Dream.
Kill them all.
OK, Cloud Build with
Skaffold-- so it builds
all the artifacts in parallel.
It has a very aggressive,
smart-caching mechanisms,
so that any image that was
already built and pushed, even
was a different tag, you don't
have to go through the whole
build process, and you don't
have to add an additional YAML.
You should really
try Cloud Build.
It's very efficient
for that, but there's
also lots of
additional use cases
that you might want to explore.
For example--
PRIYA WADHWA: Cool.
So David just talked about how
we can use Skaffold and Cloud
Build together to build our
images remotely on the cloud
while doing local development.
But we can also use Cloud
Build and Skaffold together
to create a continuous
deployment pipeline which
will push your application
to your Kubernetes
cluster for you.
So let's talk about what
this would look like.
Say you're a developer, and
your code lives on GitHub,
and you want to and add a new
feature to your codebase.So
the first thing
you're going to do
is develop locally, hopefully
with Skaffold now, and get
your feature up and running.
And then push those
changes to GitHub,
and as soon as they're
merged to master,
that's where our
pipeline will come in.
So Google Cloud Build--
we're going to use a
Google Cloud Build build
trigger to watch your repo.
And it'll know whenever
you've merged a new change
into your codebase.
And once it sees that you have,
it'll pick up your new codebase
and run a skaffold
run on the codebase.
And that'll redeploy
your new feature
to your cluster,
at which point you
can visualize whatever changes
you made as you normally would.
So this is the
pipeline configuration.
We have another
Cloud Build YAML.
But this is basically
what Cloud build
is going to run on
every code change.
So the first step
is pretty simple--
it'll just get credentials
for the cluster
that you want to deploy
your application to.
And the second step is just
a skaffold run, which we've
done a bunch of times now.
So it'll rebuild your images,
push them, and then redeploy
your application for you.
DAVID GAGEOT: I just
want to say something
that's very important.
We showed you you can use
Skaffold on your machine.
But you can use it on Cloud
Build or CI/CD system.
Because since you've
listed all the artifacts
you want to build,
since you've listed
how you want to
deploy them, you can
do that from Jenkins or
anywhere for that matter.
So really, this is what
Priya is showing you.
She's going to run
Skaffold from Cloud Build,
instead of what
we've shown where we
ran Cloud Build from Skaffold.
PRIYA WADHWA: Yeah.
DAVID GAGEOT: Which is--
OK.
PRIYA WADHWA: You can
do it any way you want,
in whatever combination.
Well, let's do a quick
demo of how this works.
So I'm going to go back to my
colors and change them again.
Except this time,
let's say we're
pushing to a production
environment instead
of a staging environment.
So I'm going to want
a version control,
and not just deploy my
changes directly from my IDE.
So I'm going to commit
these changes to GitHub.
David, does it look good you?
Code review.
DAVID GAGEOT: Sorry?
PRIYA WADHWA: I'm
going say, yes.
I'm just going to
push to master.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yeah, I like
the color, so you can push.
PRIYA WADHWA: Cool.
[LAUGHTER]
So now that I've pushed
to master, at this point,
Google Cloud Build should pick
up the change in my codebase
and start a new build.
So we should check the UI.
And looks like a build
has already started.
And it'll basically
run the two steps
that I already showed in
the pipeline configuration.
So the first step gets
credentials from my cluster.
And the second step
will do a skaffold run.
And I've actually
set up my build
triggers so that they only run
when certain files in GitHub
are changed.
So this build trigger runs when
only my colors microservice has
changed.
And it'll only rebuild that
part of the application just
to speed up my
deploy a little bit.
DAVID GAGEOT: So you were in
your IDE, you just Git pushed,
and you've got a whole CI/CD--
PRIYA WADHWA: Yeah.
DAVID GAGEOT: --chain
that is triggered.
It will build all the artifacts.
It's will redeploy everything to
the production cluster, right?
PRIYA WADHWA: Exactly.
DAVID GAGEOT: Cool.
PRIYA WADHWA: And if we
take a look at the logs,
we've downloaded
our Skaffold image,
and now we're
rebuilding the image.
DAVID GAGEOT: In reality, you
don't have to look at the logs,
right?
PRIYA WADHWA: Yeah.
You don't actually have to.
It will just happen.
And we're pushing.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yeah, pushing.
PRIYA WADHWA: And we
should be done soon.
Usually this takes
around a minute.
DAVID GAGEOT: Yeah.
PRIYA WADHWA: And it's done.
So if we head back
to our application,
we should see that the
colors have changed.
So that is a really simple
example using Cloud Build
and Skaffold together to
create a continuous deployment
pipeline.
DAVID GAGEOT: Sometimes it's
so quick that it feels slow.
[LAUGHTER]
You don't have to do anything.
You just Git pushed.
It's deployed but--
PRIYA WADHWA: And then
have a sit-around.
Get a cup of coffee.
DAVID GAGEOT: OK.
So a quick recap
of what we've seen.
So we've seen different ways to
develop faster with Kubernetes.
All of them are
connected to Skaffold,
which is the tool
we are working on
and that's used
underneath by Cloud Code.
So Skaffold gives you a
very tight feedback loop.
Whether you're working
locally, on a local cluster,
or remotely, you can work on
any type of Kubernetes cluster.
And we've seen JIb.
Jib is one of the tools you
can use to build your Docker
images quicker and more easily
because you don't have to learn
the Docker file syntax.
You don't have to
install Docker.
It will just use your
standard build tool
to build Docker images.
Yeah.
PRIYA WADHWA: Cool.
We looked at Cloud Code, which
lets you run Skaffold directly
from your IDE.
So you just have to
hit some buttons,
and I'll do all the work for
you, which is really nice.
And then we also looked
at Cloud Build, which
can build your images
remotely on the cloud,
and also will help you
set up a full [? CD ?]
pipeline for your
Kubernetes application.
DAVID GAGEOT: OK.
So that's about it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]